WINNIE LAM: Hi, everyone.
Hi.
So I'm Winnie Lam.
I know it must be hard to pay
attention when there is a much
cuter turtle on the
big screen.
But anyway, it's my pleasure
to welcome all of you guys
here to the talk today, and of
course, our speaker, Dr. Caleb
McClennen, who is the Marine
Conservation Director at the
Wildlife Conservation Society.
So he's going to talk to
us today about oceans
conservation, about turtles,
and how we can help by
participating in swimming
with turtles in Belize.
So let me tell you about how
Caleb and I first met, which
he's looking at me
nervously about.
I don't know why.
But anyway, so when Caleb and I
met for the first time a few
years ago, I remember that day,
I was wearing the exact
same thing that I'm wearing
right now, which is this
funky, ridiculous-looking
turtleneck.
Literally, a turtleneck.
Anyway, so we got chatting.
We hit it off, got talking
about turtles.
And then sometime later, he
told me that he needed
volunteers to help his
scientists with a turtle
population survey in Belize.
And so as far as me being a
big turtle fanatic, I was
like, yes, please sign me up,
and I'll bring a bunch of
Googlers with me, too.
And so there we were last year
in Belize swimming in one of
the most beautiful oceans
of the world.
And I was really excited that I
got the chance to touch and
hug a turtle.
And I'd like to think that he
was hugging me back, too.
Anyway, so without further ado,
please help me give a
really warm welcome to
Dr. Caleb McClennen.
[APPLAUSE]
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN:
Thanks, Winnie.
And thank you all for taking
some time out of
your day to be here.
It's really a great pleasure.
And we look forward to talking
a bit more about turtle
conservation, a little bit about
what WCS, the Wildlife
Conservation Society,
does in Belize and
elsewhere for turtles.
And then how, like Winnie said,
some of you may be able
to help if you're able to come
down and spare a week in the
tropical seas swimming
after turtles.
And there's a few folks here who
did the trip last year, so
I might call on to just provide
the real story behind
what I'm saying in terms
of the turtle surveys.
But the results we got back
last year is that it was a
really positive trip, and we
tweaked a few things to
hopefully make it even
better this year.
So look forward to questions
throughout.
I'm sure the style here is if
you've got something to ask,
no need to wait for the end.
But also leave some time
for questions.
Today we'll just talk a little
bit first about turtles just
to get a sense of why--
besides the fact that
they're cute, yes--
but why we care and why we're
spending a lot of time and
effort, and why it's worth your
guys' time besides the
ancillary benefit of nice
weather and maybe a tan or a
sunburn to think about them.
So I'm just going to provide
an overview of the three
turtle species we primarily see
at Glover's Reef, which is
where the survey takes
place in Belize.
The three turtles we'll talk
through are loggerhead turtle,
green turtle, and hawksbill
turtle.
So this is a photo of a
loggerhead turtle similar,
actually, to Winnie's photo.
This is in the New
York Aquarium.
The photos often for loggerheads
are very popular
aquarium species.
And so you'll get these crystal
clear shots, which if
anyone says was taken in the
wild generally are taken at
the aquarium.
Loggerheads we see down in
Belize but are actually one of
the main turtles on the
southeast US coast.
Most of the nesting and a lot
of loggerhead habitat is in
the Southeast US.
So the United States government
and a lot of
community organizations in
Florida, Carolinas, throughout
the Gulf, have a big role
in the conservation
of loggerhead turtles.
Of course, the Caribbean plays
an important role as well.
They use the Caribbean
grounds.
But in some ways, the Caribbean
experiences the
benefits or costs of good
or poor US management.
You may see some loggerheads
down at Glover's, but it's not
necessarily the dominant
species.
One of the biggest impact for
loggerheads is by catch and
trawl nets.
You've probably heard a lot
in the news of trawl nets
scraping over the bottom.
US has done quite a lot, and
other countries as well, to
try to design nets that
don't catch turtles.
But still, there's quite
a lot of damage.
And just recently, I think
there's a lawsuit launched on
the West Coast here in
California on loggerhead
mortalities for the Pacific
population.
Because they think about
1,000 a year are
killed in net drownings.
Turtles breathe air, so if they
get dragged under for too
long, they drown and die.
So anyway, the Northwest
Atlantic loggerhead might see.
The second one is the green
turtle, one of the largest
turtle populations
historically.
Historically, green turtle
populations were 30 to 90
million individuals in the
Caribbean population,
Caribbean and Western
Atlantic.
And now they're down to less
than 300,000 is the estimate.
We don't absolutely know,
because there's not a perfect
annual turtle census.
But this is massive orders
of magnitude.
So sort of post-Columbus surveys
coming in say that
green turtles were just
everywhere as far as the eye
could see, similar to what you
think about as cod up on the
East Coast or some
of the salmon
fisheries you have here.
Just massive quantities.
But the big problem with
green turtles is they
taste really good.
Green turtles eat sea grass.
They're the only fully
herbivorous sea turtle.
And they're consumed
by populations
for hundreds of years.
They're also very easy to keep
alive on colonial ships and
trading ships.
You simply turn them upside
down and you can keep on
feeding them and keep them alive
for a very long time.
So green turtle populations were
decimated historically,
and then even in some places
until the present day.
This photo is of a green turtle
on sea grass beds,
which is where the dominant
green turtle habitat is.
So usually you'll see green
turtles on sea grass beds.
But you'll also see them
at Glover's Reef.
And so it's our second-most
common turtle that we have out
there in the atoll.
And then, the most iconic turtle
for coral reefs is a
hawksbill turtle.
And this is a turtle that's also
known-- you'll see turtle
shells in general are quite
charismatic, but particularly
the hawksbill shell was used
for turtle jewelry.
And still in some places
today, even though it's
illegal, is used for
turtle jewelry.
They feed over 90% on sponges.
So they're feeding on
sponges on those
reefs, those big, barrel--
They eat all the different
colors and shapes and sizes
you see on coral reefs.
And their populations as well--
estimates range from
the sort of pre-contact
populations of half a million
to 1.5 million in
the Caribbean.
So in order of magnitude,
less than green turtles.
But now they're thinking about
12,000 nesting females of
hawksbills in the entire
Caribbean right now.
So when you see a hawksbill,
that's a few blocks of the
city of San Francisco.
12,000 individual female
nesting hawksbills.
So very small population.
But you do see quite a
few at Glover's Reef.
And interestingly, it's a lot
of juveniles that are there.
So it's a quite important
habitat for a life stage.
And it also lets you, as you
see Winnie hugging the
hawksbill, they don't actually
look too big when you see them
there, because they can be
close to a little over a
quarter of a meter when they
first come and arrive.
But primarily being focused
on coral reefs as well.
I didn't mention about green
turtles-- green turtle nesting
is huge in the Caribbean.
Tortuguero in Costa Rica is
maybe a place a lot of people
have heard of, has historically
been a very
important nesting ground for
green turtles and has been
very successful there.
And hawksbills tend to nest in
a lot more sporadic areas.
So even the smallest of islands
in Belize and other
places in the Caribbean can
be quite important for
hawksbills.
They nest all over
the Caribbean.
So these are the three species
that you'll see
when you're out there.
Of course, many other people
know of leatherbacks, olive
ridleys, Kemp's ridleys.
There's a number of other
species that are out there.
These are the ones
that you see.
And of all of them, the
hawksbill is the most
threatened out at
Glover's Reef.
And for that reason,
it's a big priority
for WCS right now.
So what makes the turtles
so vulnerable?
There's the issue of the
historic catch, and I'll talk
about it in a little bit.
One of them is they have this
life stage that makes them
incredibly accessible but
incredibly vulnerable.
So we all know of nesting
turtle beaches.
And one of the biggest successes
in the amount of
effort we put out there
to protect turtles.
This is a turtle nesting in
South Water Caye, just west of
Glover's Reef, so a little
closer to the mainland.
And it's a hawksbill laying
its eggs in the sand.
But right at that moment of
nesting, there's a number of
different things that
can happen.
You can take the turtle and
eat it in some places.
The eggs can be crushed.
The eggs can be predated
on by other animals.
And beaches can be used
for development.
Lots of lights can go up.
So the nesting process for
turtles has made them
incredibly vulnerable.
That explains a lot
of the loss.
Once they get out, as probably
most of you know--
this is bigger than life
size right here.
So when they first come out,
they're very small.
This is a baby hawksbill
actually off of our program in
Nicaragua where we protect a
great number of hawksbill
nesting beaches in the
Pearl Keys on the
Caribbean coast of Nicaragua.
And a typical clutch will put
out a little over 100 eggs,
but only about 1% of those will
survive, because as they
come out in the water, they're
extremely vulnerable.
How many people have been to
turtle nesting beaches and
seen this either on vacation?
And then how many people
have seen it on TV?
OK, right.
So you've all sort of
got a sense of it.
If you haven't seen it, one
of these times when
you're in the tropics--
and usually you've got to go out
late at night-- it's very
much worth your while to go
check out a nesting beach and
see that act of either a turtle
laying their eggs or
the hatchlings being released.
But this second part of their
life stage or wherever you
[INAUDIBLE] also incredibly
vulnerable.
Not only the getting off the
beach and getting out into the
ocean, but then they're
essentially floating around in
the middle of the ocean
for a while in
these convergent zones.
So the Sargasso Sea in the
Atlantic is quite important,
because a lot of marine life
aggregates there in their
developmental stages.
And they're just going to float
around there until they
get to be about 20 or
25 centimeters.
And then they'll swim back to
some feeding grounds where
they can survive.
So you have a very vulnerable
strategy for them as well,
which they're in trouble with
just natural predators.
But then when we bring in human
impacts-- so this is a
historic map of St. George's
Caye in 1764 recreated for a
publication in the 1960s.
And I'm not sure if you
can read it there.
But on this map of this small
settlement, there was a
trading post--
are a bunch of turtle corrals,
so places where they brought
the green turtles in and kept
them until traders came and
they could sell them.
It's estimated that
for about 200
years in Belize's history--
which was British Honduras
at the time--
turtles was the primary fishery,
the primary marine
economic engine of the colony,
which is not something that
even enters our mind today that
sea turtles could be the
primary driver of economic
activity.
So this historic hunt and
harvest of turtles was a big
part of the decimation.
And then still in the 1960s,
people were actively and
legally harvesting in
Belize, in this
case, loggerhead turtles.
They have a bunch of loggerheads
stashed up, and
then cleaning out
the carcasses.
Turtles are going to take
anywhere from 30 to 50 years
to have their first clutch.
So things that happened in the
'60s, '70s, and '80s are still
having their impact today.
A one-year commitment
to turtles
doesn't really mean anything.
A 10-year commitment to turtles
doesn't mean anything.
It's a very long-term commitment
to start seeing the
results of your actions
take place.
But this historic meat-first
meat harvest.
And then in the Victorian Age,
in the late 1800s, turtles
started to be used
for jewelry.
So the hawksbill shell was
starting to become a prize
jewelry until fabricated
materials
started to replace them.
So that played a significant
contribution.
You see some examples of the
hawksbill jewelry, which you
say, oh yeah, I bought
sunglasses
that look like that.
So the pattern imprint of
hawksbill shells are still in
our fashion design
sense today.
Or maybe a barrette you have.
Even though, most likely, most
of that that you have now or
hopefully what you have now,
unless it was passed on from
grandparents, is not from
hawksbill shells.
But you see the volume of
carapaces that can be
collected for this
type of trade.
And then also, this is actually
a photo from only the
last 10 years in Nicaragua where
direct harvesting of
eggs takes place just to eat
the eggs directly, not to
raise them up or anything
like that.
So a number of different uses of
the shell and the products
of the turtle.
So we talked about the historic
hunt of sea turtles.
But just to continue to paint a
grimmer and grimmer picture
for what, frankly, in marine
conservation is something that
we've done a lot of
good things for.
But it's just important
to recognize
that this is happening.
Still in the Caribbean, there
are legal hunts of turtles
going on today.
And then, as I think probably
most of you know, turtles are
swimming throughout
all the countries.
So a turtle we find in Belize
one year might be over in Cuba
later on in its life stage.
And it may have been born
in the Windward
Islands in the Caribbean.
So they're moving around
quite a bit.
But these are photos from our
program in Nicaragua where
it's estimated still about
10,000 green turtles are taken
a year in a traditional harvest,
not for export but
for meat consumption.
So there's still a great amount
of pressure on sea
turtles today.
The expression--
I just thought I would mention
it here, though it's a little
bit morbid to say it--
of turning turtle comes from
once you turn a turtle over,
they can still survive,
obviously,
for a very long time.
They're still breathing air.
This is how they'd be
transported on ships across
the ocean for their meat.
They would stay fresh,
but they weren't
going to be going anywhere.
And then finally, like I
mentioned with the loggerheads
earlier, the issue of bycatch
is something you
hear quite a bit--
turtles getting caught
up in shrimp trawls.
Any type of bottom trawl is
catching the same things that
turtles are eating.
So those are big opportunities
for turtles to be taken up in
those trawls.
A lot has been done.
Turtle exclusion devices or TEDs
have been innovated to
try to inhibit the amount of
turtles that are taken up.
But still, as long as you're
fishing on the sea floor,
there's a good chance
that you could be
collecting marine turtles.
Sometimes you think about
wildlife conservation or any
type of conservation, and
there's one major thing you
have to do.
And you can potentially, if you
do that one major thing
like create a protected area
or stop the trade in ivory,
then maybe that's going to make
a significant difference.
And with turtles, there's just
all these different components
to the threats that have
happened through different
timelines that are also
happening with different
constituencies.
And what I would like to do next
is move towards some of
the optimism side.
So a lot of this stuff has
happened in the past.
And now there's a patchwork, but
internally, increasingly
turning into a considerable
amount of effort by WCS of one
of many groups that is out there
helping to save turtles
and protect turtles.
And a lot of governments that
are out there as well.
And Belize is really an
interesting story and where
the work we're going to talk
about at the end comes in is
an interesting time in the
history of protecting turtles,
essentially.
So here's a review that was done
by Piniak and Eckert two
years ago just looking
at how turtles are
protected in the Caribbean.
The gray areas are complete
protection.
The dotted areas are protected
with some exceptions.
Most of those exceptions are for
traditional or artisanal
or customary type hunts.
Those could vary from the
Nicaragua case of being
thousands and thousands of
turtles to only a few turtles
taken every year in some
jurisdictions.
And then you have, actually,
full legal fisheries still
happening in some countries
as well.
So even though some parts of
turtle exploitation are
well-governed and protected,
there's still a patchwork of
management.
And as I mentioned before,
turtles are going to move
between jurisdictions
quite a lot.
This, by the way, are the
exclusive economic zones of
countries out to 200 nautical
miles or the halfway point
between countries if they abutt
each other, as they do
in the Caribbean.
But Belize, in many ways, has
come almost full circle.
It was on the map as under full
protection, because there
is still the potential for an
exception for customary take,
although it's not used.
Has come the whole way in terms
of turtle protection,
such that now, the Fisheries
Department of Belize, who
you'll be working with when
you're there on the trip, is
taking care of turtles,
untangling them from gear.
And if anyone ever were to be
harvesting turtles, has a
relatively robust enforcement
effort out there protecting
for a number of different
marine things.
So the Fisheries Department of
Belize, the country of Belize
has come quite a long way from
historically, when that was
the dominant part of
their economy.
Just to trace it back a little
bit, the first efforts to
protect turtles in Belize
were in the late '70s.
Under the Wildlife Act, there
was an attempt to protect
turtles fully.
But it conflicted with the
Fisheries Department that was
trying to have some sort of
catch controls and managing
the harvest.
So really, for the late '70s all
the way through the '80s,
there was still ongoing
take-and-harvest of turtles.
Another effort was made in the
early '90s that was a full
protection of hawksbill
turtles.
If you remember from the
beginning, now we're talking
only about 12,000 nesting
females today in the Caribbean
of hawksbill, so extremely
vulnerable.
So a full protection of
hawksbill and then size limits
for other turtles happened
in the early '90s.
And it wasn't until 2002 that
Belize put in the full
protection for all species
of turtles.
But now, I don't know how much
you talk to people who are
working in conservation, but you
hear about what the real
law is and then what the reality
is on the ground.
And it's taken quite
a long time.
But now, for the most part,
most turtle harvesting the
people have heard about
in Belize has stopped.
So for three decades, there's
been this slow wrench-down on
turtle harvesting to the point
where it's quite rare today.
You still have entanglements or
things where they'll need
to be freed, but there's not a
direct and there isn't too
much of any sort of black market
activity going on.
Interestingly, Belize, because
it was part of the British
government when CITES, the
Convention on International
Trade in Endangered Species,
stopped trade in turtle
exploitation around the world
that was signed in the '70s
when Belize was still
part of the UK.
And so when Belize declared its
independence afterwards,
there was a sort of a convenient
ignoring of the
fact that they had signed
it when they
were part of Britain.
And so it was not actually
in effect until the
late '80s for Belize.
So the Japanese imports of
hawksbill turtle carapaces and
turtle products in the '80s
were still spiking quite
considerably from Belize.
So there's still these pulses
in the '80s while wildlife
protection measures are trying
to happen on the ground, not
having the impact
that they have.
But today, turtles are
quite protected.
Belize also leads as one
of the most robust
marine-protected area
systems on the
Mesoamerican Barrier Reef.
So this is a map of Belize.
The Barrier Reef is on the
east side right there.
You can see it extending all
the way down from Bacalar
Chico to Sapodilla Keys.
Glover's Reef is just
the offshore atoll.
You can see it's all in green,
meaning it's all part of a
marine reserve.
And so the government of Belize
not only has been
protecting turtles but is
increasingly protecting a
number species, setting aside
areas for no fishing zones,
and creating a number
of different places.
And just about a month ago,
Turneffe Atoll right here was
just declared as the newest
marine reserve in Belize.
So the government is continuing
to advance not only
protection of turtles but the
entire marine ecosystem.
Which when you think about all
those different impacts, is
what it's going to take
to conserve turtles.
So just a quick background of
WCS in Belize to get us to the
point where we'll talk
about the trip that
we're thinking about.
This is an aerial view of
Glover's Reef atoll where now
one of our base of
operations is.
WCS has been operating in Belize
since the early 1980s.
And we worked to help declare
some of the first marine
reserves or the first marine
reserve in Belize--
Hol Chan Marine Reserve has
since moved on to help manage
Glover's Reef, South Water
Caye, and to helping the
government of Belize and a
number of their different
measures, historically,
to protect
turtles, to reform fisheries.
We have a large program to work
on shark conservation
throughout Belize.
So we're doing quite a lot in
Belize to help manage the
marine environment.
Belize, as you probably know,
is a global priority for
marine conservation, because it
sits on a very biodiverse
Mesoamerican Barrier Reef.
We have about 20 staff in
country, a lot of them out on
the station, some of them in
Belize City that you'll meet
as well, most of them Belizean
who are working to
conserve the area.
Just a few shots of some of the
other things that exist.
So we're talking about turtles,
but other really
important species and iconic
species that are out there on
the reef as well.
Anyone know what these are?
Gander?
Failure.
No.
So they're Nassau grouper.
You can tell by this little
spot back here.
And Nassau grouper are
ecologically extinct
throughout a lot of
the Caribbean.
They have this unfortunate
habit, similar to turtles, of
coming together at part of their
life stage where they
become really vulnerable.
They come together to spawn.
Historically, fishermen have
decided to put nets around or
hooks and catch them.
But we do quite a lot throughout
Belize to protect
Nassau groupers.
And now, all known spawning
aggregations of Nassau
groupers are protected,
including Northeast Point at
Glover's Reef, which has a big
spawning event in February,
March every year.
Belize has cetaceans like a
number of other countries.
This is actually the
first dive I ever
took at Glover's Reef.
And I turned around and heard
the whistling of a beaked and
bottlenosed dolphin that
just swam right by.
There's not any exploitation
with these species going on
right now, so they're safe.
But they do obviously have a
historical legacy in they
change the dynamic of
the environment.
Elkhorn coral is very
vulnerable.
It's on the endangered species
list in the US because of
disease and climate impacts.
And it's the main reef-building
coral.
If you see this when you're in
Belize and in the Caribbean in
general, you're quite lucky,
because a lot of stocks have
been decimated in the '90s, and
now they're starting to
come back as well.
But Elkhorn is one of many
species of coral that is quite
important and worth thinking
about conserving.
So here's a shot
of Middle Caye.
This is the research station
on the north point of the
island, which is actually
the left side of your
screen right now.
The rest of the island is now
being left to restore its
natural habitat.
And there's a trail that goes
around the outside.
This is where we conduct all of
our research operations as
well as we host the Fisheries
Department that runs all their
enforcement patrols from
the station as well.
They have an enforcement tower
as well as a number of
different equipment in their
boat that they can go out to
look for violations of
the marine reserve.
And you run into them there
as well on your turtle
monitoring.
The station itself has several
dormitories, a galley, the
Fisheries base classroom.
We are as solar as we
can possibly be.
We have a very large solar
array that basically can
manage the load when
people are there.
Although we do have backup
generators if the demand is
really high, if people are using
a lot of electricity.
We also take all of our water's
coming off of the roofs.
The toilets are all compost,
but they smell quite fine.
As much as possible,
we try to be an
eco-friendly research station.
It's great for our mission, and
it's great for the planet.
It's also the way to
live on islands.
For any of you that have been
on remote islands or out in
the remote desert, it just makes
economic sense as well.
So here's another photo of
the team from last year.
And going in now to talk about
the surveys that you'll be
doing in Belize or at least some
of your friends will be
doing in Belize.
I think a really important
question is to hear why, with
everything we talked about,
why is it important to be
conducting these surveys?
These are the only in-water
surveys for
marine turtles in Belize.
Right now, if you remember, the
hawksbill, which is the
dominant species we see out
there, is the most critically
endangered of all the
turtles in Belize as
well as in the Caribbean.
There's this long life cycle
issue from when they are born
to when they start having
offspring as well.
So if we don't monitor and
learn about what habitat
they're using, what's happened
to the populations at a number
of places around the Caribbean,
these species can
blink out before you necessarily
know it.
And so at this point in time,
while the population levels
throughout the Caribbean are at
the bottom of their curve,
we hope, or potentially still
declining, monitoring simply
the status of a population,
getting a sense of their size,
how old are they, getting a
sense of their health, their
use of the reef, do they
use certain parts
of areas over others?
Because if they do, maybe we
should have more protections
there just to make sure there's
no incidental catch.
That type of information
is really critical.
Plus you'll see the Belize
Fisheries Department, some of
our staff, and some of your
students from local schools
come out building up national
pride around sea turtles and
about understanding their
biology and their importance
is quite strong as well.
So the sea turtle monitoring
absolutely is a core
priority for us.
And the thing that makes this
trip interesting is we need
the human power to do it.
We can't do it.
We only have a few staff on
the station, so we need a
bunch of people out there.
As the folks that did it last
year will tell you, it is
difficult work.
It's a lot of work out
there swimming.
But it is what's critical
for us to achieve our
conservation.
So I think I'll just
take a moment here.
This is one of the Belizeans
coming up with a hawksbill.
The basic idea of the turtle
surveys is we transect the
entire atoll with a number of
different line transects.
And you're looking both for
sightings of turtles and then,
if possible, you're
capturing turtles.
Not forever, but capturing them
to measure them and to
take health assessments and a
number of different things.
Obviously, the capture rate is
quite different than the
sighting rate.
And so we're not able
to capture as many
turtles as we can sight.
And last year, a few of the
volunteers were able to
capture some, but we're
still able to
capture 20 or 30 turtles.
I guess with this slide up here,
I should ask if someone
who was here last year maybe
say one or two things about
the experience out on
the water while
they were on the trip.
Want to go for it?
AUDIENCE: Basically, the
water is amazing.
So sometimes you'll have really
good visibility, and
you can actually see the ocean
down to 100-feet deep.
You can see from the boat
down to the bottom.
You can see sharks and coral.
So basically, you're
floating along the
top looking for turtles.
And if you spot one, you kind
of raise your hand, and you
can wait for one of the
Fisheries guys to come help
you catch it.
Or you can kind of attempt to
free-dive and catch a turtle.
But these guys can free-dive
to 75-feet deep, so maybe
that's kind of a little deep
for your average swimmer.
But basically, you got to kind
of sneak up behind them if
they're sitting on the ground.
Because if they see you,
they'll kind of dart
off and swim away.
So you kind of try to come
up behind them and
kind of grab them.
So these guys right here--
I think they're doing
a relay, because the
turtle is so far down.
So they would actually grab
it and then pass it off to
another guy, because they're
holding their breath really
long and these turtles
are kind of
fighting for their way.
You want to add something?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's a bit of teamwork.
Catching the turtles definitely
takes a bit of teamwork.
Often, we'd send one person
to go down and--
as Elaine was saying, you have
to sneak up on them.
And you can burn a lot of air
waiting until you grab it and
then hand it off to somebody
else who's maybe a little
fresher to swim it up
to the surface.
And then there's other people
on the boat who take it from
you as you pull him
out of the water.
And they are ready with tape
measures and things like that
to weigh them and tag them.
AUDIENCE: But it's pretty
amazing, because once you get
them to the top, we get to do
measurements like how wide
they are, how long they are, and
take little tissue samples
for them to send back to a lab
and do analysis on them.
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Great.
AUDIENCE: You just have to work
a little bit to focus on
the task at hand and not get
distracted by all the pretty
things in the ocean.
The visibility is ridiculously
good by
Northern California standards.
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Great.
Thanks, guys.
Yeah, so we do want to
have a sense of that.
I hope you got that it is some
work as well as fun, but
there's obviously
some wonderful
distractions to have.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, do you
ever use scuba?
Or it's all--
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Not for
capturing the turtles.
So we do do scuba for a number
of the different type of
surveys that we do
and the research
we do out at Glover's.
But not for this, because
you have to bring
them up to the surface.
So the decompression issues.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How long are they
out of the water?
[INAUDIBLE]?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: It's about
a half hour that you can
keep them up there.
Did you guys have it timed, set
you had to worry about?
AUDIENCE: I think
Winnie's been--
I don't think we had them
out for half an hour.
WINNIE LAM: Well, so,
I have to confess.
I was the weakest swimmer
on the trip.
And I discovered this pretty
much on Day One.
I was swimming in the transect,
and then the WCS
person on the boat kept telling
me, swim faster, you
got to keep up with the crowd.
So eventually, I just ended up
staying on the boat most of
the time to do the measurements
and the tissue
sampling that Elaine
was talking about.
But in terms of how long we were
spending, I think it was
probably half an hour for
each kind of excursion.
And then we would take the boat
off for a 20-minute ride,
and then we would go off to
another spot, and then we
would do another survey at that
other spot, et cetera.
So I would say it's probably
a half hour to an
hour for each stint.
AUDIENCE: Then we were in water
and the turtle was out
of the water for maybe, I don't
know, 5 or 10 minutes,
as long as it takes to weigh
them and measure them and
sample them and tag them.
WINNIE LAM: Yeah.
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Great.
Obviously, the minimum amount
of time as best as possible.
Well, let me go through a
couple more slides here.
So a turtle comes up
to the surface.
And if you're lucky, that's you
or your friend who spotted
the turtle, and they went down
and got it or passed it off.
Then there's this measuring of
the carapace, which we used to
be able to get the age
of these turtles.
And you see some of them,
again, are quite small,
because Glover's is really an
important area for juvenile
hawksbills and some
adult greens.
And then you're there getting
ready to put the turtles back
in eventually.
As soon as you got all
the work done, they
go back in the water.
We can put mercury capture tags
on them if they haven't
been marked before.
A lot of these turtles have
spent over a year at Glover's,
particular the hawksbills.
So they have already been
tagged, and so we'll just make
that note in the data set.
I'll keep on taking questions
on the trip
in a second as well.
But as just a quick overview
to give a sense of--
this is Glover's Reef in
a quick schematic form,
absolutely not Google Earth.
But we're looking at about 50
kilometers long lengthwise,
and then all the transects
that were swum by
the team last year.
And the blue is the hawksbill
turtle on those pie charts.
And this is the summary, is
the vast majority of the
turtles you're collecting are
hawksbill turtles in blue, and
then greens, and then
a few loggerheads.
As well as a few unknowns when
the turtles were too far in
the distance out there.
But you see last year we caught
between 70 and 80
turtles, which is
actually a lower
number than years before.
So hopefully, things do tend to
go up and down as we-- so
we have that maybe we'll see a
few more this year as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Yeah.
Some of the statistics that we
do is sort of taking into
account how the data
that's coming in.
And so sometimes, maybe there's
multiple people seeing
the same turtle, so we have to
take into account that sort of
duplication of effort.
Is that what you were
pointing out?
Or something different?
AUDIENCE: We had some problems
getting in line with
[INAUDIBLE].
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN:
Oh, I see.
Yeah, making sure you're not
running over people's
transects or moving.
Yeah.
So just this is not Glover's
Reef, and it's not a mistake.
So this year, we're going to be
purchasing a satellite tag,
so that you can live with your
turtles for long after you
leave Belize.
And there's a great website,
seaturtle.org, which is a
nonprofit in and of itself but
also a coalition of nonprofits
working on sea turtles.
And they'll publish the results
up on their website,
so you can track your turtle.
This is actually a leatherback
from Gabon from a partner
organization, University
of Exeter, that we
worked with in Gabon.
And you can see tracking a
turtle all the way across the
Atlantic Ocean.
Your turtles in the Caribbean
most likely will not go all
the way across the Atlantic,
but we'll see.
So this year, we're going to add
that element, which will
add a little bit more to the
time in the surface, because
you actually have to fix
on the satellite tag.
We'll have one or two of those,
which would make for
some interesting data
coming out as well.
As well, we're going
to be looking at
fibropapilloma virus.
It's a disease primarily in
green turtles in the Pacific.
It hasn't been investigated
yet in
Belize, so we're going--
WCS as well is running
conservation programs around
the world, also runs
four zoos and an
aquarium in New York City.
And a great side benefit of
that, or a primary benefit, is
we have tremendous veterinary
capacity.
So our chief vet's going to come
down this year and help
do some health examinations of
the turtles there to see how
healthy they are, what type of
disease they may or may not
have as well.
So that'll be another thing
keeping some of the turtles
out of the water just a little
bit longer this year but also
add to some more information
we can learn about the
population, particularly for
hawksbills, where we want to
try to mitigate any sort
of impact that's
experiencing them.
So just to close, and then
I'll take on any other
questions we have, a reminder
is this turtle survey is one
piece of our efforts
at Glover's Reef.
It's a very important piece.
We're doing a lot of other
work at Glover's Reef.
You will do some transects and
work on corals as well as a
sort of side benefit of this.
But we're doing a lot
of work there.
Also, for the turtle work, we
spend a lot of time and effort
in Nicaragua where there's
great mortality of green
turtles, like I mentioned in
the beginning, still today.
We work to protect hawksbill
beaches in the
Pearl Keys in Nicaragua.
We work with some partners in
Panama to protect hawksbill
turtles as well.
And then we have
a set of sites.
We work in the waters of 20
countries around the world.
We have about 250 staff,
mostly nationals of the
countries, where we're working
on different types of ocean
conservation for coral reefs and
hawksbill turtles in the
Caribbean, western Indian Ocean,
and the Coral Triangle
here, as well as some of the
most important areas for
whales, coastal dolphins,
leatherback turtles in Central
Africa, as you saw on
that previous image.
So this is a piece
of what we do.
It's a very important piece, but
you're also partnering up
with an organization that's
doing quite a bit for ocean
conservation.
And so it's an exciting
organization to work for and I
think an exciting organization
to join, at
least on this trip.
So with that, I'll just
take any questions.
I sort of threw a lot at
you in 40 minutes about
what's going on.
So I'd love to answer any
questions about turtles,
conservation, or other.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I actually
have two questions.
How long are you in
the water per day?
Because it's like half hour
stations, so is it--
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Yeah.
Well, so there's a morning
session and
an afternoon session.
The morning you will spend
monitoring the turtles, and
then the afternoon, some
days you have flex.
So obviously, you're an adult,
so if you decide you don't
want to go in the water, no
one's going to be whipping you
and getting you in the water.
But several hours
in the mornings.
Is that about what you guys
spent when you were on the
turtle surveys?
But then when you're not in the
water and you're on the
survey, you're in the boat.
So moving from one transect
to the next.
So it's quite a lot of
time in the sun.
And so you see most people
are wearing skin
suits, hats, all that.
You need sunscreen, but you
also want to make sure you
have as much material on
your skin as possible.
And then when you're not on
the turtle survey, there's
other transects that we're doing
for coral health and
other pieces.
We had talked about, actually,
at lunch, an idea, which is,
we are really good
at conservation.
We're not technical experts in
thinking about how to manage
information, how to collect
information in the way that
you guys are.
And so this would be the
second year of this
partnership, provided we have
eight people sign up.
And it would be really great
to think about, well, what
could you guys bring in terms
of technical capacity and
thinking about how your
expertise could combine with
our expertise.
And so some people I talked to
about potentially bringing
some underwater cameras to fill
underwater image archives
or automated image collection or
a range of different ideas.
So we'd be really open to
hearing about that either when
we're on the trip or beforehand
as you're signing
up, saying, I got a great idea,
and I've got someone I'd
like to trial it with.
AUDIENCE: And my second
question is--
I was just in Gili, and there's
turtles there as well.
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN:
In Indonesia?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And we were told explicitly
by dive masters
not to touch them.
Is that just a--
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Well, you
should absolutely not touch
turtles or coral or anything
in the water.
It's better not to touch them.
And so these slides which we've
shown are not a slide
of, hey, you should book a
vacation to Belize, go to a
hotel, and go grab a turtle.
If that's the take-home message,
then I should be
fired and I will be putting in
my application to work at some
other place.
No.
It's a cost benefit of--
in order to save these species,
which are critically
endangered, we need to
understand them more, we need
to be protecting them, and we
need to understand if our
protections are working
or not.
Because so far, there's a lot
of decline in populations.
So some of the cost is the
tactile aspect of touching
these animals, doing
health investments.
None of that is done for just
pure, ha, I wonder type
science investigations at this
point, because they're so
threatened.
So by no means should this be
thought of that, yeah, you
should touch things when
you're on recreation.
We do fully believe when you're
in the ocean, you
shouldn't be touching things.
And if you think about it, the
number of people who are doing
research is a pretty small
amount of people.
If you take that amount of
touching and then say, all
people that happen to go on a
hotel vacation in the tropics,
your impact magnifies
pretty quickly.
So that was a long way of
saying, no, they're
right, and I'm wrong.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: What are the
currents like?
I assume it's protected since
it's a reef, but--
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Well, you
are on the outside and most of
the transects on the outer
shelf-- and it is pretty much
a wall in most of the places.
If there's heavy currents-- and
you guys correct me if I'm
wrong if you went out when there
was too heavy currents--
if conditions are unsafe, we're
not going to have you
doing surveys.
Because sometimes there
are big seas.
I was just at Glover's in
October, and we had 6- to
8-foot seas.
And we're scuba diving.
That's quite a lot to
be bobbing around.
So generally, we want
to be doing them in
close-to-flat water.
There's a dive master and a boat
captain on the boat that
would just be making that
call and making
sure it's not unsafe.
Obviously, currents also mess
with your transects.
So generally, it's
not very good.
Did you guys have much current
when you were--
Yeah.
Incidentally, Glover's is known
as one of the best dive
spots in the Caribbean
as well.
And that's not because it has
a ripping current that will
sweep you out into the ocean.
It's just got fantastic
wall dives.
Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you have tanks of
air or anything [INAUDIBLE]?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Yeah.
We are not a scuba operator.
We're not an eco-tourism
operator there.
But there are great eco-tourism
and scuba outfits
there that we will set people up
with who we've worked with
for a long time.
And they're raising the profile,
so that's absolutely
an option in your time off
when you're not doing the
turtle surveys.
Well, I've got mixed reports
where either you'll be
extremely exhausted or you'll
have extra energy at the end
of the day.
But definitely, you should take
advantage of diving when
you're down there as well.
And if you don't decide to
go on this trip, going to
Glover's Reef and signing up
with those resorts to dive on
your own is a great
idea as well.
Yup.
You're right there
in the middle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so
we can go back again.
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Yeah.
You can also book them.
Some people, I don't know
if they took advantage.
But we did say the rain forest
is pretty amazing
in Belize as well.
WCS helped set up the
jaguar reserve there
a long while ago.
And so the rain forest and all
the other sites in Belize are
quite important.
And the zoo as well.
We've got a vote for
the zoo as well.
Right after you go
to the Bronx zoo.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the fitness
requirement?
I know you said that a few hours
in the water, but how
long do we actually
[INAUDIBLE]?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: You should
be a strong swimmer.
I think if you're a strong
swimmer, you'll be fine.
So if you're just learning to
swim or if you're not so sure,
if you couldn't say, yeah,
I'm a strong swimmer--
I don't mean Olympic swimmer.
But if you just know you could
spend an hour or two in the
ocean no problem, you're fine.
But I wouldn't underestimate.
I think we learned a bit is that
you do need to be quite
able to hold your own
in the water.
But that being said, there's
also work on
the boats as well.
So if you have a question about
that, we could chat
about it more and
figure it out.
AUDIENCE: Does WCS have other
conservation efforts in Belize?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Well,
so we work in--
And just to quickly show you
the Belize map here.
We work in South Water Caye,
which is to the west.
And then we have shark
conservation work off of
Gladden Spit and also throughout
the country.
We have a number of different
shark conservation projects,
particularly Lighthouse Reef.
I thought it would be easy
to go back, but it's
taking a long time.
So just to quickly show you, so
we work in Glover's South
Water Caye.
These two make up about 33%
of the affected areas.
Lighthouse for shark tagging.
And then we do have some shark
research going for a number of
different places as well.
We do not have current
terrestrial projects right
now, if that's what
you're asking.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
question, but is there an
internet connection from where
we would based?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: I
don't know why you
would ask that question.
I need to make a joke
about last year.
Last year we had our
presentation here, and our
computer didn't work for like
half of the presentation.
It was like, of all
the places!
There's Wi-Fi, and it apparently
worked quite well.
I think you can do everything
you need to do.
You're not going to be able to
stream video, but there's
Wi-Fi at the station itself.
So in the evenings, a lot of
people use their computers and
do what they need to do.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, the question
was related to what you said
earlier on that you were asking
about people who could
use their skill sets and people
who could use data
skill sets.
Would they be able to do
it from the island?
Or would it be before
or after?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: It's a big
issue for us to figure out
how to better manage our data.
People were asking about, when
are we done with all the
results from last year?
And we're still working
on the processing.
A lot of it's just capacity,
but we could start the
conversation before.
But I think when you're
there, you'll be--
Robin Coleman is our Assistant
Country Director, and she's
the scientific PI on this.
She would be there to talk you
through, OK, this is how we
manage our data.
And if you had ideas or
if anyone [INAUDIBLE]
trip ideas about how to improve
that, make it more
accessible, get it out,
we'd love them.
Like I said, we're focused on
the conservation, and there's
a lot of areas we can improve
on that side.
So absolutely.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] your
contact information and
[INAUDIBLE]
discussions.
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: Yeah.
I left a few brochures
up here.
One just with the what we do for
oceans generally, one on
our Belize program generally,
so you can get a bit more
background idea.
And there's a sign-up sheet,
which you don't really need,
because you can use the email
that was sent to you and the
website and all that.
But if you feel like signing
up just to get more
information, we'll make sure we
kick out some more to you.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How well are
the [INAUDIBLE]
protected?
Is there a lot of illegal
fishing or shark finning
pressures or anything
like that?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: So most
of the marine reserves in
Belize, the areas that are part
of the marine reserves,
almost all the shark fishing
has been effectively
controlled through a lot of
intense investment and
enforcement.
However, it is still
legal to fish shark
outside of the reserves.
Within the reserve itself-- so
if this is a marine reserve,
only a portion, I believe,
is a true no-take zone.
So in Glover's Reef, it's the
southern portion of the reef
that is a no-take zone where
there's no fishing whatsoever.
And then a smaller portion which
is absolute wilderness,
which is pretty rare
in the ocean.
Enforcement varies per area.
So we've been working at
Glover's for a while, and I
would say I am very biased.
But if you trust me and I say
I'm being objective, our
enforcement numbers are very
strong in terms of compliance
at Glover's Reef right now.
We've just moved to South
Water Caye, which is the
biggest reserve in Belize and
has a very large no-take zone.
And the Fisheries Department is
saying, we need help with
enforcement, we know there's
infractions.
And we're trying to figure out
solutions to help them and
putting more resources
into South Water.
So it's not perfect, but some
areas are quite well enforced.
Most of what you see on there as
a marine reserve has people
on the ground or in the
water that are out
there, are able to.
It's a matter of if they
have enough people.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you said earlier, the
surrounding areas were very
dependent on turtle
harvesting.
Has that changed?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN:
Historically, Belize before it
was Belize, when it was British
Honduras, as a colony,
the turtle fishery was the
dominant fishery for several
hundred years.
It was the most lucrative and
the biggest thing that was out
there, which says something
about the relative size of the
colony but also the abundance
of turtles at that time when
you're talking several
orders of magnitude.
Today, turtles are worth
a lot for eco-tourism.
They're not worth anything in
terms of financial resources.
In other countries like
Nicaragua, people are selling
green turtles on the local
market, 100% for meat
for $25, $35 each.
So there's a small
micro-economic dependence there.
In reality, it's actually more
of a protein dependence,
because 10,000 turtles is
quite a lot of meat.
But as a driver of trade, CITES,
the regime I mentioned
previously, has effectively
banned most turtle trade for
the shell or for the meat.
So now, if you looked
at analysis--
I'm sure there are
some out there--
the value of turtles is
tremendously larger in terms
of just scuba diving and
people seeing them.
But not anymore.
Fisheries are still
quite valuable.
And shark, as you mentioned,
shark fin is quite valuable in
the places that don't
protect shark.
There's a lot of money coming
in for the fin in Belize and
everywhere in the world.
AUDIENCE: Will you still be
doing the lionfish surveys?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: The
lionfish surveys will be part
of the coral transects.
I think we're deciding what
we want to include in the
non-turtle transects.
So that's still up in the air,
and we're deciding exactly
what that will be.
So yeah.
The other half, when we weren't
surveying turtle last
year, we did lionfish surveys,
because lionfish is an
invasive species that's now
pretty much ubiquitous in the
Caribbean, unfortunately.
It used to be that you saw them
out in Asia and Papua New
Guinea and Fiji.
And you thought, this is
amazing, I haven't see a
lionfish, wonderful.
And now that moment is ruined.
But you also look at them in the
Caribbean and think, oh,
it's just really devastated
the areas.
Other--
This is the last question.
AUDIENCE: Oh!
[INAUDIBLE] shouldn't
waste it.
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN:
No, waste it!
AUDIENCE: I just didn't
know why they're
devastating the area.
Do they eat coral?
DR. CALEB MCCLENNEN: There's no
known predators right now
for a lionfish, and they
do eat to survive.
And they eat a lot of smaller
reef fish that you'll see.
And they've only been around
for about 15 years, so the
impact we don't really
know yet.
But we know that other cases of
an introduced species have
been quite devastating.
We're trying to encourage things
like lionfish hunting.
There's a lot of ideas out
there about what to do.
They're here to stay, in
reality, because of currents.
Great.
Well, thank you so
much, everyone.
Really appreciate the time.
And probably, for any of you
that know more in depth on one
of the topics we covered today,
there's a lot more here.
And I hope some of you anyway
could come or pass the word to
come to Belize and learn more,
and like a few of you
indicated, help us think about
ways to advance our
conservation through what
you know about.
But great pleasure.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]